[Music]
what's up everybody it's episode 180 of
congratulations
okay you know dude here we go man and we
tried to start this podcast
already and we [ __ ] it up and so we
had to start it again and we wasted two
minutes and it's all good dude do we
waste two minutes yeah it's fine did i
overreact a yes
am i probably going to get into trouble
later yes
am i probably in trouble now yes because
overreacted is all good don't even worry
about it you guys that's behind the
scenes footage speaks of behind this
footage
so drunk um is uh
you can join my patreon uh it's
patreon.comcrystalia
and what i have on there now is you can
join
uh and you get the full extended ep you
get the full extended episodes
a day early and there you get an extra
episode a month
and then there's an uh and there's all
sorts of like i've been posting stuff
all week just extra content on there uh
and uh it's been a lot of fun man
and there's another tier that's higher
there's the second tier where part of it
is we have this
this group discord chat i don't know
what to [ __ ] call it i'm 41.
and um we are on there
and we uh and i we chat and i've been
like chatting with everyone
and and like they're like don't hey
don't you have stuff to do
and i'm just like i'm like oh it's just
fun you know and i realize that i'm a
[ __ ]
big loser so it's all good i just don't
have much to do i i the only thing i do
all day is i wake up i have my [ __ ]
coffee
i hang around with the family and then i
uh and then i you know
i [ __ ] i build my shoulders and my
teardrops man i build my toe
my shoulders and my uh and my and my
teardrops which are my my quadriceps
above my knees and i said
um and i said a few a few things wrong
there what did i say
my my toddlers my toddlers did i said
tolders and i don't think i forgot
do not think i forgot that i [ __ ]
said tolders uh
so anyway um i'm chilling dude
uh so join the patreon
patreon.comcrystalia
um because we don't have ads anymore uh
and
and i [ __ ] it but it's up to me i
this up this episode is brought to you
by [ __ ] cinnamon toast crunch like i
give a [ __ ]
uh man i there's so much [ __ ] happen
that i haven't talked about and
and and all that by the way i love chet
hanks
i love chet hanks that's it that's it
that's it i don't want to talk about it
anymore i love chad hanks no you know
what i am going to talk about it
that dude is on another level of
of uh performance art the guy
when he made up the white boy summer and
then people were like
dogging him on twitter because of white
boy summer here's what i would have done
i would have left it alone
i would have made the one i would have
you know i i love when people come by i
love when people come up with terms dude
and like coin [ __ ] like so when you put
white boys summer i was
all in i could have been a [ __ ] asian
girl i still would have been all in
and um and then but
i would i would leave it alone like when
people come back and
and hit back and start to hate i just
want to leave it alone like i said what
i said but this
dude is on another level he's smarter
than all of us
the he came in with the [ __ ] response
and look what he says wow white boy
summer going up it's fantastic hold on
let me start it over
this guy i love this guy
here we go
and the sound's not playing white boy
summer going up it's fantastic i love to
see it
thanks for making that a thing uh you
know they've been asking
thanks for making that a thing is the
most
subtle diss you know
cause he made it a thing wow white boy
summer's going up thanks for making that
a thing
dude he's like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you were making fun of it and now it's a
thing
thanks for making that a thing just so
ill how we laid into it right there
gonna be a white boy summer does that
make it a black queen summer for you
and i said uh do you know me
and i said uh do you know me by the way
there is no situation
where you say do you know me
that isn't that doesn't automatically
make you the
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know for real
batman could be here and he would be
like
i just saved your whole family and you'd
be like
oh cool and you'd be like yeah and then
you'd be like
you have a you have a nice house what do
you do for a living
and you'd be like uh do you know me
batman would be like
oh anyway i so uh
and just zip line out of there like a
[ __ ]
ugh my bad i don't know maybe you're a
doctor or something i noticed that
[Applause]
i thought i noticed a diploma at an lsu
in the other room
and maybe you'd do dental but anyway
just zipline the [ __ ] out dude i always
thought it would be funny if bat
batman tried to zipline out with his
[ __ ] utility belt and he thought that
there was no ceiling but there was a
ceiling and then he just [ __ ] broke
his neck and died and the batman credits
run
that's how the justice league the new
one the [ __ ] new ones the director's
cut
justice league yeah what what's the
[ __ ]
di
da
[Applause]
[Music]
do the batman song you could sing for
nine years it never stops
anyway you're welcome for saving your
[ __ ] lives
oh no and then just i can't feel my leg
and then the house
burns with him in it and he dies and
everything's [ __ ] and his face is all
charred up but his
arms and legs are okay because he's in
that [ __ ] [ __ ] bat shoot that
saves
for some reason makes him know like he
has a [ __ ] makes him like a tank
anyway if you did you know that's all
year round
ah when he goes dude when chet hanks
turns his head and goes
that is
that's the illest [ __ ] i gotta adopt
that that has to be my thing now
sorry chet but that's my thing now
no i can't do it as i mean the guy the
guy has the perfect face for it
but yeah he did the white man wait wait
what
well there's a way funnier white man
summer i wish that's what it was
hey it's white man you [ __ ] a bunch
of middle-aged guys and
[ __ ] dockers and that that blue no
the blue button-down shirt with the
with the pink salmon shorts that
everyone wears and goddamn
maine and connecticut if you i think
i've said this i must have said this
before
we're doing reruns today babies we're
doing reruns
um the pink salmon [ __ ] pants
that people wear with like penny loafers
and the button-down shirt and the
braided belts
um if you don't have that you live in
connecticut you don't really live in
connecticut
you're you're you're a you are made in a
laboratory
try to think back when you were six can
you no because you don't have a [ __ ]
memory of it because you weren't six you
were made as a 30 year old or
probably a frat guy like a 22 year old
anyway let's listen uh yeah if you want
to know more about the white boy summer
hit the link in my bio and register for
actors advantage my acting community i'm
dropping where i'll be sharing all the
game all the gems on how to get into the
game
and actually make a living from being a
working actor in film and television
if that's something you're interested in
you know what i mean so uh hop on the
right foot
and make your next move your best move
is you know what's good for you
and uh you know everyone have a great
saturday peace love and light
bye can't believe how
amazing that take was i know don't know
what's better to think of chet hanks
only doing like i'm gonna get this right
the first time
getting it right the first time or i'm
gonna do this till i get it right and
he's sitting in his car and did it nine
like nine or 12 times i don't know
what's better but god damn that's funny
man
huge ch chet hanks fan
um
we were watching a little bit of [ __ ]
qvc the other night or whatever it was
and it was so great i
i don't know what it is about qvc that i
no i know what it is that i love
but like i could just watch all day long
like my brother said by the way it's my
birthday
we were recording this on my birthday
i'm 41 years old
um and my my brother said for your
birthday i got you
we're gonna go to a hotel and we're
gonna chill in the hotel and we're gonna
watch infomercials all night and i was
like dude
you could have gotten me a heavy gold
bar
and it wouldn't have been better than
that i mean that's just
you know [ __ ] a
night in a hotel room with my brother
watching infomercials dude are you
kidding me
[ __ ] yeah dude
so fun i can't wait to do that [ __ ]
and here's why i love watching
infomercials because every infomercial
the person selling the thing
doesn't give a [ __ ] about the thing
and it's still happening ah
it's been happening for decades
and people are too stupid
to catch on or give a [ __ ]
you think that [ __ ] gives a [ __ ]
about the shark vacuum it's a vacuum
no it take cleans up more [ __ ] than the
shark one
this is the shark too so what the [ __ ]
was with the shark one then
it left some hair [ __ ] y'all for that i
don't trust you
this is unbelievable here and we've only
got you know what we've got
i don't know if we have that many left
do we i love when they trail off do we
have that minute left we had some from
the other okay
we'll bring them in here yeah okay see
these are going
just all serious about and they don't
give a [ __ ]
about it
limited edition always it's never just
stuff
limited edition it always seems like
there's
one extra syllable in there but it's
there's not some reason they do it
magically
[Laughter]
we have got
anhyzer bush bottle caps
limited edition
limited-edited edition we have got
we've got three what do we have 30 left
they're gone they're gone we found more
we've got limited edition
anhyzer bush
bottle caps
it's my favorite so how could you not
listen to a guy
that you know is lying knows he's lying
how could you and still sell sometimes
it's the same dude
that sold you the other [ __ ] [ __ ]
the the [ __ ] projector that made the
house look all christmassy
or halloween the good thing about this
the good thing about this projector is
you can use it on any holiday
or any day of the year that's my
favorite because it's like who the [ __ ]
what do you want to project in your
house
just tuesday in may
i get halloween it looks like a ghost is
in the window and someone's stabbing
someone on your front door
or christmas there's like a long red arm
with a white
glove coming out of your living room
what the [ __ ] but you could use it every
day
i use my and i use mine every day lie
everyone knows it
ka-ching
also there's they're so janky you ever
[ __ ] order something
from that it shows up it's like bro it's
always like
you're like this is it it's all plastic
that's what you always think this whole
thing is plastic
i love qvc [ __ ]
and we're gonna throw in that's my
favorite part
we're also gonna throw in some of my
hair
we will throw in as supplies last
some of my hair that's my favorite is
you get the whole set you act
right now
you'll get some of my hair you know what
i'm just gonna do it we're gonna give
you
phil's hair phil come here show him your
hair we're gonna cut
some of phil's hair we'll send it out to
you they don't give a [ __ ] those guys
are hookers dude
um
oh speaking of cereal we were talking
about [ __ ] cereal how about the
shrimp tails in the cinnamon toast
crunch
that's what i was [ __ ] talking about
jesus christ must've been on my mind
there were shrimp tails in it
did you guys know this there were shrimp
tails found
in [ __ ] cinnamon toast crunch
hey cinnamon toast crunch
[Music]
pack up leave
leave the facility yeah it's all good
you had a great run
yeah we had a great run dude
you sold candy a cereal for [ __ ] 90
years
then you added fish
that's it go ahead there couldn't
have been a worse well no well
syringes
no you know what a [ __ ] really small
person
that's the only thing that could have
been worse syringes are a really small
guy that came out of the box
it's like hey what's up i mean i was in
here for
like so long i'm so glad you opened it
what the [ __ ] are you only wearing a
t-shirt yeah
they didn't give me pants
i [ __ ] hate sin i will never eat
cinnamon again and then you just [ __ ]
does this does that run away
um yeah just shrimp tails were in it
that's so disrespectful that not even
the whole shrimp was in it
just the tail like some [ __ ] factory
worker was like
[ __ ] it drink it with milk [ __ ]
and they came out with the cinnamon on
it dude the guy who tweeted it
wasn't he [ __ ] tapanga's husband or
something from the boy meets world or
what was that this thing
and uh he was [ __ ] uh yeah
topanga canyon's husband and she and
and he was like hey yo cinnamon toast
crunch he tweeted him and he was like
i got shrimp in my [ __ ] cereal and
they were like
oh is that to happen after the factory
you could tell because it's not
and he and then he took a closer picture
and he was like it's coated in shr
in [ __ ] cinnamon it's coated
where would it get coated but at your
[ __ ] factory
but maybe it is their [ __ ] mistake
that's the other thing well it doesn't
matter
it's not like they're gonna go out of
business
uh yeah so
but for a limited time you get
cinnamon shrimp and your cinnamon toast
it's not toast crunch totally
it's shrimp too dude shrimp is in there
[ __ ] that's gross ew dude i love shrimp
and
after that i was like man maybe i won't
eat shrimp anymore shrimp's all [ __ ]
up dude they're all like this
just in the [ __ ] ocean and [ __ ] are
they even good for you
you think about it like you think about
like oh yeah they're good because it's
fish but dude shrimp
they're bottom feeders dude
[ __ ] gross eyes out of there
they're snails you know i saw something
about a snail earlier what the [ __ ] was
it about the snail that i saw
i don't know um
how do i go back to facetime there we go
um
yeah man i i uh
i taught i talk um
i i talk about you know what i realize i
do so much is i'm i'm
so all in on being a dad right right now
like that i've not or i should say now
that i have my
son and it's all i do all day and think
about and talk
and talk about and just i watch him i
watch my son
and he doesn't even know i'm watching
and i'm just i catch myself just like
staring at him like an [ __ ] while
he's like trying to peel stickers off
and it's like imagine if like you did
that to a 40 year old
like i just i i just he's 13 months you
know and i just love
i love him so much and i'll just stare
at him and
uh
and he's ju and i so i talk about him so
much and i know i do that and i know a
lot of you like that
i don't know if some of you don't like
that but i just i'm still
so jacked on being a dad
that i can't help it i just can't help
it
i just like i was brushing his teeth
today
in that where we were brushing his teeth
and it's so [ __ ] cute dude
because like you just you you put the
first of all he wants
everything but the
to have his teeth brushed like i'll take
the toothbrush out
and he'll be like what is that and then
i'll take out the toothpaste and be like
give me that too i want the two things
and then i'll [ __ ]
and then i'll take out the the and then
i'll i'll turn the sink on to do the
water on the toothpaste and he'll be
like
the sinks what is that i'll put my hand
in that water i want
it's coming down i want to feel that is
it
translucent i don't understand you can
grab it you can't grab that
and um and then when i put the thing on
the toothbrush i put it in his mouth
he's just all like
what what's what's going on here and
it's like you want all the things just
relax let me do the thing
and so i put i put the toothpaste i put
the toothbrush i go to brush his teeth
and and and of course he just like if
this is the toothbrush he just goes like
this
i'm just like nobody and then by the
time i take it out all the toothpaste is
off and he's just like
bubble gum and uh it's a bubble gum
flavor by the way which why don't they
just keep that
it's awesome have you ever had kids
toothpaste i was like what is this is it
is le i thought i was like is it less
minty than it normally is for adults
because it's pretty minty you don't want
the kid being like is my head going
explode
and so i i tasted it and i tasted it i
was like i tasted bubble gum and i was
like great got a tumor
gonna die because if you ever think
about tasting something and then it's
not it's totally not the thing that you
thought it was
that might i jump to tumor city
i'm the mayor tumor city and i'm the
mayor
hello guys and uh
tumor city population one nice to meet
you
i'll be here a few months and then then
i'll be gone so
very nice and uh
and so i um
yeah so so i i put the it's but it is
it's bubble gum so hey
toothpaste companies that [ __ ] rips
keep that why are we brushing our teeth
with mint
when the kids [ __ ] is the [ __ ]
i want to brush my teeth with a [ __ ]
bubble gum flavor [ __ ]
that is so banging and calvin loves it
dude
at first he doesn't want to do it but
then when he does it he's all
he just and i'm like trying to move it
and he just moves his head with it and
i'm like no you got to go against the
[ __ ]
but it's really cute dude there's a
little ass teeth
and then i try to do the top ones you
don't give a [ __ ] but dude it was just
so cute man
i love doing that i love doing that i
sent we we took a video sent
to my mom and my mom was like wow you
sure got a lot of patience and i was
like
it's so fun
what's that say um
yeah so i don't know man
um he's gonna have a complex though i
we love this kid so much i swear to god
like
we're so involved and i thought in the
beginning it was about the pandemic
because i thought like oh great i'm
gonna have a [ __ ] pandemic baby he's
never gonna know anybody until when we
get this all figured out
and now i realize that oh this is just
how it is i would just wanna be
like dude i don't wanna go on the
[ __ ] road and not be around him for
four days
and um so he's got so i'm always in his
face just like hey hey hey
and he's just gonna grow up and be like
he's just gonna think [ __ ] in the
like when i walk into rooms i've been
talking about this with my therapist but
i didn't realize this about myself when
i walk into rooms
i immediately and this is for year
decades
think everyone in here [ __ ] hates me
i got to win them over and i said that
to my therapist
i didn't think it was a big deal and she
was like hold on a second back back up
because then i started talking about
[ __ ] pants or some [ __ ] like i
like to try to like skim the surface a
lot of therapy
you know it should be like no no go back
to when you said the thing about how you
think everybody hates you in every room
that you ever walk into
and i was like but there shouldn't be
cargo pants are you sure there's
pressing issues
and she was like yeah it was about the
thing and i was like i just imagine that
people are gonna hate me
she was like how long have you done that
i was just like
ever
ever since when i was in kindergarten
and the [ __ ] teacher grabbed my face
when i did something wrong and
squeeze it too hard
and told my mom about it ten years later
and she said if that happened that's not
okay and i said
but i was wrong right
and she was like uh no and so so i was
like yeah no every room i walk into and
and she was like oh that's sad
and i was like now
no it's fine i
i win him over i went him over with my
comedy or
i help him out or if they spill a drink
i'll clean it you know
it's fine she's like no it's sad
and i said
no it's not sad it's
fine it's normal it's
you know it's okay she was like
well let me ask you a question um
why don't you think that they like you
and i was like
i don't know i don't know maybe i know
they're
maybe they like know my comedy and they
don't like it or something or
or maybe they just don't like the way i
look or are there i look like an x of
theirs and they're
just don't like because of that she was
like
oh what if they
what if they like you and i was like
yeah and look i don't
if we could just get back to cargo pants
i just think they have too many pockets
and she says look
i i
calvin your son and i said
yeah she was like
well you love calvin right
and i said well of course i do and she
said
why
and i said
he didn't do anything to
she said he didn't do anything to earn
your love did he
and i was like
no
she was like whoa
maybe people just like you because
because
you think i didn't cry
you think i didn't cry on the zoom
dude she said maybe they like you
just because and after the [ __ ]
one-two punch with my son
my eyes went
[Music]
filled up with little pools of water
and when those got full
they emptied dude out just go
boom and i go
and i caught him like tom cruise when
he's trying to [ __ ] hack the system
in mission impossible 94 or whatever it
is
maybe people just like you because and i
[ __ ]
cried oh
that is so beautiful you know
um yeah so
kind of makes you think been trying to
walk into rooms now and hope for the
best
but yeah so but joe biden fell
uh did you see joe biden fall
by the way something oh
i was gone for like nine months not
doing this podcast there was
one moment where i was one because i
didn't want to be funny or do anything
uh i just was moping around and but
there was one moment dude
i talked about a while ago if joe biden
was president
you know he's too old because imagine
him hearing a gunshot
do you remember do you remember this do
you remember this okay
and if you know somebody is too
old if you hear a gunshot and you
first of all an able-bodied regular
person
i'm ready right but old people when you
get too old if you were to hear a
gunshot
they go hey where is it you're dead
dude all over your [ __ ] old head
just [ __ ] tommy gun in your [ __ ]
you know because that's the gun you
think of because it's the old-fashioned
gun but but so i was
you know imagine the [ __ ] i mean take
barack and this isn't the democrat thing
i don't give a [ __ ] democrat
take barack pal barak he's ready
donald trump's old pal donald trump i
feel like
he's on his way but joe biden
pop where's a hooted
all up in his neck and face and just
and [ __ ] and and
[ __ ] so when he got a nog
or one or whatever the [ __ ] even though
you know even though it's documented
he's a hologram and donald trump is
still the president
even though it's well documented that
donald trump is only
is it's still donald trump and he's
wearing a [ __ ] joe biden
skin mask um
the balloon popped or something and
and joe biden [ __ ] did that
he did that the balloon popped and joe
biden goes
and he was in a line with his family
everyone in his family went
huh there was a [ __ ] baby that
even was like i got this joe biden goes
like what did i
did i draw my keys
he did it and i was like i [ __ ] want
to talk about this so much find the clip
it's out there
um anyway uh
anyway yeah
but he fell dude he fell here's
also how you know he's very old
he fell
walking up the stairs
three times
there's much nothing more [ __ ] than
falling
up the stairs
dude because i'll tell you why you fall
down the stairs
everyone gets it that's where gravity's
going so if you don't have
footing you're going there too
but if you fall up the stairs you're
just not really that sure where the
stairs are
and you only caught the [ __ ] stair
with your tippy toes so [ __ ]
and then you fall and it makes that
noise bump
and your shin if you're lucky you don't
hit your shin on the step
and then you try to grab whatever's
there you miss
or you or even worse you grab
one a little bit and then you you fall
the other way because you're holding
which is what happened
i gotta watch this now dude i have it
right here
biden falling up how the [ __ ] do you
fall
up the stairs three times in a row
i love the noise of the jet
there's one up wow caught himself with
the left hand again and
and then again wow the second one is or
the
the second and third one is a double one
just figure out where the stairs are and
then he turns around
and salutes hey dude no the [ __ ] army
was like no no no no no
no no no no no you fell up the stairs
[Laughter]
dude if i [ __ ] were to fall up the
stairs and people were
i would be so angry he is the president
i if i would just you can't get angry i
would be i would
immediate if i if i did that i'd go [ __ ]
[ __ ] and i turn around to the news and
be like [ __ ] [ __ ] you bbc
i fell up the stairs dude whatever i'm
president dude [ __ ] off i'm getting in
the
this is my plane look how big it is and
then i
i'd go backwards on the stairs
dude you fell up the stairs three times
in a row that's hard
to do that's harder than playing cuphead
i tried to play cuphead you know i
thought you were playing video games in
the cup heads just wait too did i talk
about this last
yeah on the other cuphead is the hardest
game it's beautiful it looks awesome
it's got that like 1920s cartoon style
[ __ ] and it's so awesome but it's so
[ __ ] hard
and we were so angry that they put out
an up that
it was so hard that they put out an
update of an easier version
and so we got that beat all of it and
then realized we couldn't fight the
final boss because you got to do it on
hard
hey dude [ __ ] come on please
make it so we can get to the final boss
there's one more boss we bonded so well
[ __ ] cuphead dude
how about when people get so mad that
you're not speaking up about issues i
saw somebody
a comment under one of the [ __ ] this
big star's instagram's like why haven't
you
mentioned the thing about why haven't
you talked spoken up about it was
something about
i don't even know it was like that whole
[ __ ] silences
violence thing where it's just like
nah what
silen you can be you can just not know
something's going on
it doesn't make you part of the [ __ ]
kkk
people act like they love it that it
rhymes silence is violence
by the way have you ever seen violence
that [ __ ] is never silent you can't what
are we
ninjas violence is so [ __ ] loud
violence is the it was so let's the
loudest people get
pop pop
you see guys get stabbed and [ __ ]
no it's [ __ ]
violence is violence
leading up to violence is silence
then you move a little bush
just go the other way go around the
other way the bush is in the way
the push is in the way go around the
other way
the push is in the way what
just get your phone i'm gonna text it to
you
i'm gonna text it to you the bush is in
the
[Music]
silence silence then we'll do violence
oh the bush oh the bush
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
go around him okay
there he is okay let's murder him
okay but do remember as silent as
possible
okay
get the gun i thought you [ __ ] had it
what
you have the gun i told you to [ __ ]
bring the gun
it's in the [ __ ] car we're [ __ ] 12
stories up how the [ __ ] are we gonna go
[ __ ] it [ __ ] you know what honestly
it's better actually
that we don't have the gun you know why
because guns make too much noise and the
second we pop that gun we're 12 stories
up everyone's going to hear it
and everyone from the 11th story down
they're going to turn on their lights
are going to see us running down
perfect so instead of that
we'll [ __ ] choke him we'll choke him
until he expires
[ __ ] yeah okay cool here we go
you wanna do it or me go
get him get his arms [ __ ] [ __ ] hey
[ __ ] get him
honey get the gun i got it bang bang
bang bang bang
get her
we gotta get him
really throw up get him [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
we got him [ __ ] go whoop whoop
that's [ __ ] violence
anyway uh that's my whole point dude so
silence can sometimes just be silence or
you can just not really know that the
stuff's going on
anyway uh i'm out of breath how long has
that been
one hour well you know you guys have
been a lot of fun dude
uh mostly because you're not talking
back and it's just me kind of talking
but uh you know just uh
remember life [ __ ] rips man
uh and also uh
you know you got to you can get them
more people are asking me can i buy
merch
yeah dude just go on my website and get
[ __ ] life for people it looks [ __ ]
awesome when you wear
i'm not big into wearing shorts and a
long sleeve but man i'll tell you what
that life rips hoodie with the [ __ ]
shorts the life ripped shorts looks dope
as [ __ ]
i gotta go against my sh my i don't do
it but i see other people do it i'm like
i gotta start doing that
um because i repost them on my instagram
a little bit and then also uh
the [ __ ] uh that we got beach towels
that say life rips man
life's gonna rip at the beach bathing
suits it's awesome dude
hey guys so that was the episode of
congratulations
but it extends you can catch the rest
of the episode over on my patreon which
is patreon.comcrystalia that also gets
you access to
uh an extra episode a month among other
things go check it out you can sign up
right now and uh
and listen to the rest of the episode uh
if not thanks
and if you do thanks
you